schon wieder versucht die wichtigste
wochenzeitung deutschlands die zeit
zweifel an der einzigen methode die wir
haben um die welt zu verstehen
die wissenschaft zu sehen das ist
unverantwortlich leichtsinnig und
bösartig früher hieß es die bild liegt
heißt es jetzt die zeit lügt designs
wars jetzt in klicks um science and
future gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
ich bin empört und muss schon wieder
dampf ablassen über die zeit nach dem
die zeit schon vor drei wochen meinte
dass künstler substanzielles zur
diskussion über die maßnahmen und die
wissenschaft zur corona pandemie
beitragen könnten mit fragen wie warum
wird denn der und der wissenschaftler
nicht öfter gehört versucht sich die
redaktion jetzt offenbar mit einer
breitseite gegen die einzige methode
über die die menschheit verfügt um
überhaupt wissen zu erwerben gegen die
wissenschaft das ist obszön
niederträchtig und unredlich zitat die
wissenschaft hat eine glorreiche
vergangenheit weil sie die welt wird
mächtig verändert hat nun wird sie von
der realität widerlegt wer soll da noch
vertrauen
ich bin wirklich außer mir denn so wie
dieses zitat werden dieser artikel wäre
zu viel er für dieses machwerk naive
einsichten mit falschbehauptungen gepard
denn es ist eine ganz klare und dreiste
gemeinde lüge dass die realität in der
pandemie die wissenschaft widerlegt
hätte sie hat das genau gesagt nie getan
sondern bestätigt und wenn wir christian
drosten angegriffen wird und das mit
einem bezug auf die wissenschaft
wohlgemerkt dann ist das einfach nur
dumm posten wird unterstellt die dritte
welle falsch eingeschätzt zu haben bzw
die möglichkeit dass er falsch gelegen
haben können so genau weiß man das nicht
bei dem autor zitat es werden wie
zuletzt bei der dritten welle ergebnisse
einfacher modellrechnungen als
vermeintlich sichere prognose über das
was uns in den nächsten wochen
bevorsteht klammer auf christian drosten
klammer zu in überlegungen einbezogen
auch wenn von einem
wissenschaftlichen standpunkt aus klar
sein sollte dass die dinge auch ganz
anders kommen können erstens hier wird
die wissenschaft genommen und ein
vermeintlicher wissenschaftlicher
standpunkt um eine wissenschaftliche
einschätzung in zweifel zu ziehen
also ich es doch wissen schafft es ist
wird dazu ist noch mal festzuhalten
boston lag mit so ziemlich allen
einschätzungen auf den punkt richtig
begonnen von der ankündigung einer
pandemie im januar letzten jahres bis
zur vorhersage der dritten welle und
vielleicht erinnert sich ja noch der ein
oder andere bis auf den autor die dritte
welle wurde erst durch eine
bundeseinheitliche notbremse gestoppt
weil die ministerpräsidenten und
präsidentin nicht dazu in der lage waren
vernünftige entscheidungen zu treffen
ohne wissenschaft wären wir hier
untergegangen und im lichte dieser
belegten entwicklung kann ich das
machwerk in der zeit nur als geistige
brandstiftung einordnen ist eine
ansammlung von falschbehauptungen
umgangssprachlich als lügen bezeichnet
nebelkerzen die keinen anderen sinn
haben das geäußerte durch wortreiche
plattitüden vermeintlich intellektuell
erscheinen zu lassen und falschen
schlüssen erstmal zu beginn wissenschaft
ist keine richtung keine bestimmte
schule keine art und weise etwas zu
machen
im gegensatz zu anderen methoden der
begriff fast alle methoden zusammen um
erkenntnisse zu finden diese methoden
unterliegen einer ständigen entwicklung
und werden unablässig verbessert durch
neue bessere methoden ersetzt und so
weiter um zb wirksame impfstoffe zu
entwickeln wurden bei cowen hat deshalb
die besten methoden angewandt und wir
haben hier die besten impfstoffe zur
verfügung die je entwickelt worden ohne
wissenschaft hätten wir sie einfach gar
nicht entwickeln können und wenn der
autor dann in seinem artikel behaupte
zitat allerdings ist die wissenschaft
draußen in der natur eben nicht ganz so
erfolgreich wie im labor die
wettervorhersage stimmt nicht immer ein
impfstoff erweist fatale nebenwirkungen
erst im gebrauch und eine genetisch
veränderte pflanze bringt mit ihrer
höheren widerstandskraft auf ungeahnte
weise ein ökosystem ins wanken
dann ist diese aussage besonders
niederträchtig niemand behauptet bei
einer wettervorhersage dass die 100
prozent stimmen würde
niemand bezweifelt
das eine genetisch veränderte pflanze
das ökosystem verändern kann
doch impfstoffe sind eine absolut andere
kategorie und es grenzt an astrologie
und wahrsagen zu unterstellen impfstoffe
würden ähnlichen unwägbarkeiten
unterliegen wie das wetter oder
genetisch veränderte lebewesen
impfstoffe sind ganz hervorragend
untersucht und danach sicher jedenfalls
sicherer als die krankheiten gegen die
sie helfen fatale nebenwirkungen kann es
gerade nicht geben weil sie in
umfangreichen tests untersucht worden
sind und wenn sie nach im studien mit
tausenden menschen zugelassen werden
dann kann es ebenso die
wissenschaftliche konsequenz dieser
vorab studien mit tausenden freiwilligen
nur noch in seltenen einzelfällen zu
nebenwirkungen kommt wie es auch bei
astrazeneca passiert ist und diese
werden in weiteren wissenschaftlichen
studien beobachtet und noch eine
binsenweisheit zur wissenschaft sie
arbeitet mit wahrscheinlichkeiten die
relativitätstheorie ist inzwischen an
hunderten phänomenen in der realität
überprüft worden
dazu gleich noch etwas und damit so oft
belegt dass sie als gültig gilt anders
ist das bei der dunkle materie sie ist
eine hypothese und mit nichts belegt das
ist auch wissenschaft allerdings und
deswegen ist die unterscheidung zwischen
realität und wissenschaft nahe an
intellektuellem unvermögen sie
untersucht die realität alles wissen
dass wir über die realität erlangt haben
wurde durch wissenschaft erlangt es gibt
eben nur dieses prinzip wissen zu
erwerben
die veröffentlichung erinnert an die
verspäteten science wort in den science
blogs vor etwa zehn jahren und selbst
das war nur noch ein nachhall auf die
erledigten sciences in den 90er jahren
des letzten jahrhunderts die damalige
wissenschafts kritik musste einsehen
dass sie auf dem holzweg war denn
methoden kann man immer kritisieren und
verbessern aber am prinzip der
wissenschaft erkenntnisse möglichst
genaues wissen mit immer besseren
methoden zu erlangen
da ist nichts dran zu rütteln dann
könnte man auch mathematik kritisieren
oder das denken an sich doch wie sie
beide unerschütterlicher teil unserer
realität sind beschreibt die
wissenschaft die realität eine andere
methode gibt es nicht und kann es nicht
geben weil sie ja alle methoden auch
zukünftige logische beinhaltet
diese wissenschafts kritik ist nichts
anderes als eine unterstützung
reaktionärer wissenschafts gegner die
weiter zum eigenen vorteil unsere welt
zerstören wollen deswegen respekt auch
an den vorstandsvorsitzenden von
volkswagen herbert diess als er zur
kritik an wasserstoff antrieben einzig
und allein auf die wissenschaft verwies
wasserstoff ist eben ein irrweg der mit
seiner drei bis siebenfach schlechteren
effizienz als batteriebetriebene
mobilität riesigen ressourcenverbrauch
bedeutet und auch technisch nach mehr
als 50 jahren intensiver forschung immer
noch auf physikalische wissenschaftliche
probleme stößt aber egal ob er
elektromobilität klimawandel und eben
auch die pandemie wenn wir überleben
wollen brauchen wir die wissenschaft nur
sie kann uns den weg weisen und
natürlich ist kritik berechtigt aber
eben nicht an der wissenschaft an sich
sondern an schlechten methoden bewussten
manipulationen fälschung betrug und so
weiter das muss ausgemerzt werden aber
noch nicht die wissenschaft wenn die
zeit jetzt glaubt sich durch einen
wissenschaftler der irgendwann mal
falsch abgebogen ist für ihre teilweise
abstrusen thesen rechtfertigen zu können
dann liegt sie falsch die zeit ist
nämlich gerade auch dabei falsch
abzubiegen disruption krasse thesen auch
ich vertrete sie gerne hier mal aber
kennzeichne sie deutlich zum beispiel
als gedankenexperimente die sind schön
und gut aber ein nach eigener definition
unwissenschaftliche angriff auf die
wissenschaft geht so weit dass ist
absolut unter dem niveau der zeit und
unwürdig wenn man an den gründer und die
ehemaligen herausgebenden der
wochenzeitung denkt gerd bucerius marion
gräfin dönhoff helmut schmidt in deren
geiste ist dieses abdriften ins irreale
ein absolutes desaster es ist in
jeglicher hinsicht ein desaster das
einer arrivierten wochenzeitung so etwas
passiert und man kann es nur passieren
nennen denn die veröffentlichung kann
ich mir jedenfalls nur als unfall
vorstellen dass das durch die
redaktionskonferenz gegangen ist das ist
von der redaktionsleitung abgesegnet
wurde
das alles ist ein absoluter gau was ist
sein hamburg los spätestens nach dem
absurden einspruch der künstler hätte
die notbremse gezogen werden müssen
bei aller lust an der diskussion an der
anderen sicht der dinge
die
grundfesten unserer zivilisation in
frage zu stellen die wissenschaft als
wichtigstes gut dass unsere spezies erst
so weit gebracht hat ist tragisch
tragisch für die redaktion der zeit es
tut mir ein bisschen leid für die
kolleginnen und kollegen was muss in der
redaktion für eine panik herrschen dass
so etwas im wahrsten sinn des wortes
nach eigenem bekunden ein
wissenschaftliches sein weg in die zeit
findet die zeit hat ein intelligentes
publikum und stößt es so dermaßen vor
den kopf eigentlich steigen die
abonnement zahlen bei derzeit weiter
warum dann sein publikum vollkommen
überflüssig so vor den kopf stoßen die
kommentarspalten unter dem artikel
quellen über von missbilligung dieser
veröffentlichung kaum jemand ist so naiv
als dass er oder sie diesen
intellektuellen tiefflieger nicht aufs
korn nehmen würde ich kann nur raten und
dieser tipp gilt für so manches medium
holt euch mal einen wissenschaftlichen
beirat damit solche armselig machwerke
nicht mehr den weg an die öffentlichkeit
finden jedenfalls nicht in einem
ansonsten so respektablen umfeld ich
kann nur hoffen dass das nicht der
beginn eines niedergangs intellektuell
und wirtschaftlich ist denn ansonsten
kann ich mir eine welt ohne die zeit nur
schwer vorstellen
hier geht es weiter also hier zu meinem
anderen kommentar zu einem zeit desaster
zu dem ich übrigens auf linkedin und
medium viel zuspruch bekommen habe ich
habe corona überlegt was mir zu denken
gibt anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
das geht unter jedem video einfach den
abo button anklicken
bis dann bleibt dran